[Music]
[Applause]
bruce feldman fox sports reporter
college football writer for the athletic
bruce will be at the rose bowl saturday
night it's lsu at ucla that game will be
on fox
hey bruce uh glad to have you on how
surprised are you that uh ucla is
favored in this game against lsu
uh to me the thing dan that a lot of
people have
kind of had their eyes open to i think
is this might be the year it feels like
the year that chip kelly has finally
turned the corner with the bruins you
have a lot of guys who played three and
four years
he has a big time running game
two really physical running backs zach
charbonnet transferred from
from michigan he's a southern california
kid looked terrific albeit against a
really bad hawaii team and then you take
the fact that lsu is coming off of a
rough five and five year
and also lsu has two new new
coordinators both guys offensive uh play
caller and defensive play caller they're
brand new have really no experience
calling plays in a game
so i think on the that side of it it's
going to be interesting to see how
lsu tries to deal with all the stuff
that chip kelly and his offense is going
to throw at him formationally as well as
they have three really good tight ends i
think they're going to do a lot of stuff
with them and and the challenge is how
does lsu adjust to it
chip came out with oregon and and it was
new and then he went to the nfl and it
was new and then went to ucla and hasn't
had the success maybe hasn't gotten the
athletes there but is he still an
offensive innovator
the way he was when we were you know
touting him at oregon and certainly that
first year in the nfl
i think he is i think you're going to
see some really unique stuff with what
they do in the run game now i think they
have the big people up front when he
took over
it was a complete overhaul from what jim
mora had and obviously there was been a
lot of growing pains there i think the
biggest difference with this ucla
program compared to what he had at
oregon remember he jumped in with mike
belotti at first he was the he was the
offensive corner then he took over the
program but they had they had recruited
a lot of speed there um i they have a
couple of guys who can really run kaz
allen can fly but he's a receiver but in
terms of you don't see like a michael
james d'anthony thomas kind of factor in
this offense um i think that's different
for them they are going to
to really try to get you off balance and
get your head spinning and then bludgeon
you uh with physicality which is
different really than what you saw with
oregon which was everything was so fast
i mean he's got his line about how
you know back when he was at oregon they
had they went really fast and they had
fancy uniforms and shiny helmets and now
pretty much everybody else has those
options too i think the thing that
you're going to see with him and he's
actually been an innovator i think in a
lot of ways in preparation i mean he's
one of the reasons why people all
throughout football not just in college
football changed their their basically
weekly practice schedule to get athletes
ready for game day i think so there's a
lot of stuff that he probably deserves
credit for that you know maybe gets lost
as people just think about oh
he made everybody go fast and he talks
fast and all that stuff i think there's
a lot of wrinkles you're going to see
now that he has a lot of pieces he can
work with and a lot of guys who they
have a lot of buy-in and a lot of
experience and what he's looking for
the quarterback who has the most
pressure this year is who
uh
that's a good question i mean
i think you know you joking you talked
about about bryce young a minute ago i
think there's a lot of pressure on him
because the expectation is so high
um
you know for me
when you're talking about alabama what's
different this year is sarc was great
with uh quarterbacks like i did a story
a couple a week ago for the athletic
about the evolution of the alabama
offense and there's been so many
different hands in it and so many
different coaches have come and gone uh
there and made their little adaptations
i think bill o'brien and people remember
him obviously from when he was a head
coach at penn state and certainly what
he did in the nfl but sark is a big
shoes to replace because sarc was as
good
coaching the quarterbacks as anybody
who's come through in tuscaloosa and i
think what's unique there is you're
you're it's not just we've got to
replace sarc we got to replace mac jones
you have to replace five first-round
picks on that offense and so john
metchi's a really good receiver but the
receiving room at ohio state had been
i'm sorry the receiving room at alabama
had been off the charts in the last
couple of years really in the last
decade i still think there's talent but
people are going to expect bryce young
to go in there and just tear it up and
he might i mean he's a he's a really
highly regarded kid out of southern
california but the bar is incredibly
high there at alabama just because no
matter who's been there it's kept
getting better and it's going to be hard
to be better than what they were last
year or even as good i think
you're going to the lsu ucla game but if
you could go to one other game this
weekend which one would it be
uh man there's great choices um i love
the match up in in penn state uh penn
state going to wisconsin uh i think
indiana and iu as iowa is a really fun
game to me though you gotta go with the
top five match-up and it's like what
happens in charlotte with with clemson
and georgia you got so many five-star
guys on the field um i think
expectations for national title is big
especially with with georgia they
haven't done it it's been a long long
time since they won a national title
they have all these five star guys and
there's a lot of hype around jt daniels
and you know i want to see it i mean
because it's not like their schedule on
either side is is loaded this is the
heavyweight matchup out of the gate this
is also the only right team right now
that clemson is is set up to play in the
regular season so
you know don't stub your toe here or
anything like that but i i think what
you have are two teams that are really
really loaded with big athletic dudes in
the front seven especially on the d
lines and i think i would expect a
really low scoring physical game with
them and to me it's like
how well can georgia run the football
because they're down
three you know five star athletes you
know a tight end and receiver and for
this matchup and that's going to be hard
to put on jt daniels i think bruce
feldman fox sports reporter he'll be
covering lsu and ucla that'll be 8 30
eastern saturday night at the rose bowl
how would you sum up the off season for
college football
chaotic um dan to me it was such a
bombshell when it came out and it came
out basically
the week of uh big ten media days here
that all of a sudden whoa texas and oh
you are going to bolt from the big 12 to
go to the sec
to me what's so crazy about that in the
subplot in this is there's been all that
talk about
college football playoff expansion and
there was a working group with with
basically four people the aed of notre
dame the mountain west commissioner as
well as bob bolesby from the big 12 and
great and greg sankey from the sec the
fact that this was go they were having
these meetings and all this discussion
and while it was going on greg sankey
was basically gutting the big 12 and bob
bowlsby's league
it's kind of really mind-blowing
business stuff and in terms of that and
how it really
uh rocked the big 12 and again i talked
to some ads in the league that week who
were like this is the most stable we
felt like we've been in a decade and all
of a sudden now you're two brands that
really are the ones that the tv networks
care about the other ones they don't
rate it's the two that are greg sankey
and the sec are taking away i mean that
created a lot of dominoes that are still
affecting you know right now we think
that the big 12 leftovers may are gonna
probably reach out to byu and houston
and cincinnati um and ucf and so that
has a domino effect to me that's a big
part of it the nil is certainly a story
with now we've gotten used to players
posing for pictures
with cars that they just got and it's
all legal now i mean that's another like
whoa moment that where are we at in 2021
and we've come a long way
good to check in with you bruce should
be fun this year certainly a whole lot
different than a year ago at this time
where we didn't know what was happening
with the big ten or the pac-12 and now
we have doubts about the future of the
uh the big 12 or at least the artist
formerly known as but uh uh should be
fun thanks for joining us bruce we
appreciate it always a pleasure dan
thanks for having me bruce feldman fox
sports reporter college football writer
for the athletic